wands at the ready witches and wizards
because I have played Hogwarts Legacy
and I'm here to tell you all about it
Hogwarts character creation flying
combat story you'll see brand new
footage of it all in today's video
people of the internet retro Records who
are here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and today we
have a Hands-On preview of Hogwarts
Legacy the upcoming action RPG from
Avalanche software so after all this
time is this the game that Wizarding
World fans have dreamed of for years is
it finally about to arrive well thanks
to the folks over at Warner Brothers I
recently had the opportunity to meet
with some of the devs at Avalanche to
talk Hogwarts Legacy and also play the
game myself for a two hour gameplay
session so I was able to explore the
Hogwarts grounds as well as parts of the
castle itself and then I got to
experience one of the game's main
missions that's right A Story Mission
which you'll see here shortly here on
the screen now you can see my player
character complete with a Gryffindor
scarf and robes flying around Hogwarts
and taking in the absolute beauty of the
castle starting with stained glass
windows here which feature the school's
four houses now I did did get to make my
own character before this you can see a
little bit of that here didn't spend a
lot of time on this because I was so
anxious to actually get into the
gameplay I was actually pretty surprised
how in this very short amount of time I
got this character to look pretty close
to me minus the beard of course so sorry
to all you guys out there who had beards
of 15 years of age but really I created
my character pretty quickly and just
wanted to jump right in and the first
thing we got a chance to do is to
explore the Hogwarts grounds on
broomstick that's right right away grab
the broom and quickly start flying
around Hogwarts by the way guys you
might be wondering what is all this
footage running on it was running on a
PlayStation 5 using the game's
performance mode which targets 60fps and
to me it felt incredibly smooth
throughout my entire PlayStation I think
you'll see that reflected in all of my
footage that I'm sharing with you today
now was everything perfect technically
no we're going to talk about some of
that as well but by and large if it's
not evident already in my voice I'm
super excited for this game and I'm
super excited to tell you about some of
the things we saw here alright so back
to this absolutely gorgeous window you
may recall seeing this image back when
the game's release date was confirmed
they used it in a screenshot here but
now actually getting to see these
windows while I was playing the game and
flying around on them I mean it really
was a breathtaking moment to take in
Hogwarts like this now you see the water
over there in the distance well guess
what yep you can swim I can confirm
swimming is in Hogwarts Legacy it does
not appear you'll be able to dive under
or explore anything beneath the surface
but seeing that we can swim along the
surface I know a lot of fans are going
to be very happy about that now aside
from the swing stuff I just want to talk
about all the little details there are
so many details subtle touches that long
time fans of The Wizarding World are
just gonna absolutely love the castle
from what I was able to see is so
intricately designed and speaking of
these little details I mean just take
for example this offhand conversation
here that's happening between a group of
students
and have you seen how these professors
look at your clothes black looks at me
like I'm a pauper I swear the man thinks
I have fleas
I wish they'd better run and teach the
entire curriculum charms is the only
class I can stay away from or this
comment from one of the flu flame
locations which serve as fast travel
points in the game you can't imagine
it even appears other students are going
to reference things about our character
that have already happened in games such
as this comment from a Slytherin student
watch out it's the troll Slayer of
hawksmeade and even though we can't play
Quidditch ourselves you can actually fly
around the castle even inside the
Quidditch pitch I just had to go and
test this out yes you can fly around it
and then as I go and fly down low here
you'll see that you can actually even
sometimes find teams practicing
quidditch here another detail that I
absolutely loved the musical cue that
plays whenever you collect one of the
game's Field Guide pages
come on
or this one when I completed a brief
side quest I
[Music]
now we already had heard the Overture to
the unwritten it seemed like they had
absolutely nailed the music but it is so
nice to see that not only did they get
the music right but also all of these
little extra pieces these little sound
effects that are going to happen here
and there throughout the game as you
unlock different things I mean think
about the iconic Zelda sound whenever
you open up a chest or same thing with
Metroid there's that iconic save station
sound right I truly feel like they have
found the perfect little music chime for
each one of these it fits so well within
the Wizarding World they are perfectly
striking that balance between something
that feels very very familiar but also
new at the same time now speaking of
that side quest where we heard that
little chime that one actually begins
when you speak to a Hufflepuff student
named Lenora Everly just outside the
library here she's stumped by an empty
painting and has discovered that casting
lumos will have an effect of some kind
but she isn't sure what to do next so if
you go over Cass lumos in front of the
empty painting a location appears in the
painting once I managed to find the
location I noticed a large moth on the
wall here I'm gonna try Akio first
nothing happened so then I decide let's
try lumos which immediately triggers a
reaction from The Moth it begins to
circle the wand then I returned it to
the painting and was rewarded with a new
Field Guide page so this is just a small
example I think of some of the puzzles
that you can expect to encounter in
Hogwarts Legacy definitely wouldn't be
surprised if this is one of the easier
ones and also I should point out that I
had a Dev from Avalanche kind of sitting
right behind me sort of pointing out
here's how this works here's how that
works so I don't know that I would have
solved it as quickly if he hadn't been
there now when it comes to Quest you
also have the option to track quests and
when you do this Golden Trail will
appear in front of you and lead you to
the quest location here I'm on my way to
meet up with Lucan bradleby in the
crossed wands dueling club now as I was
on my way there I got to witness
something that the devs at Avalanche
refer to internally as a wow moment it's
basically when a scripted event is
triggered based on your location in the
castle or who knows maybe even outside
the castle as well but with this
particular one here I got to hear some
rather humorous dialogue from everyone's
favorite Poltergeist peeves of course
you know he's in the game and if you're
a long time fan of the series and know
your Wizarding World lore then I think
you'll appreciate this particular line
right here he tried to stop me did
rancorous cop sought to trip me can find
me inside of a jar so as I stood there
listening I happened to notice another
Field Guide page and then after casting
revelio I was able to retrieve it so
that's already two different ways here
that we've seen you can obtain these
Field Guide Pages the Little Pages
flying around as well yep you can also
use accio on those and I gotta say this
was super fun I kept getting distracted
they were trying to kind of guide me to
one place to the next I was like no I
want to go after this field guide page
right here now a bit further down that
Hall from where I'm at Peas I came
across this unlit Brazier and after an
accidental acciocast right there I was
able to light it with incendio which
again gave me another Field Guide page
I'm A Trophy Hunter you guys I'm gonna
be honest I'm already like just so ready
to dive in and look for all these Field
Guide pages I hope there's a ton of them
in this game so even in just my very
short time I think it was pretty
interesting to see kind of the wide
range of things you can do to actually
find these Field Guide Pages throughout
Hogwarts alright So eventually I did
make my way over to the Cross ones
dueling club and I got to have my first
experience with the game's combat now
everything we've seen so far of the
combat is someone at Avalanche playing
and Community manager Chandler would
stressed to us that hey look guys the
person playing this is actually really
good at the game they played it a lot
because a lot of people thought oh man
this looks way too easy well I was
playing on the normal difficulty and I
never died in my two hours with the game
I did come close a few times but I can
confirm to you guys that while the
system is easy to understand and get
into it is going to be very difficult to
master and I mean that in a good way if
you like challenge in games especially
again I was at the normal difficulty I
found it very very challenging and one
that you're really going to be rewarded
for the more you learn the system now I
mentioned being very close to dying well
thankfully in my playthroughs my
inventory included access to a handful
of Wicked World healing potions and yes
I did have to use quite a few of them as
for spells I had access to lumos which
wasn't much use here as well as levioso
Akio and incendio now the red spell that
you see being cast frequently is simply
known as a basic shot and while it only
does minimal damage it's useful for
juggling enemies to set up Combos and to
give your other spells time to refresh
from their cooldowns notice the
color-coded shields on these opposing
students which can only be broken by the
way if you cast a spell that belongs to
the corresponding color category so
notice here in the bottom right how each
Bell has a color coding with it so in
this case the only yellow one I have
here is levioso so that is what I have
to cast to break this yellow shield now
you also have your own Shield charm in
the form of protego and at first I was
almost completely ignoring it it is
mapped to triangle on the PlayStation
it's actually very easy to press it's
very easy to do and I should have been
casting at any time that I saw one of
these yellow indicators appearing about
my character the red though that means
the spell is unblockable so you're going
to need to use Circle to kind of Dodge
out of the way another aside here I've
been playing way too much God of War
recently so anytime you see me jump in
the middle of the fight I was most
likely trying to use the Dodge roll
instead which I know that's going to
come with practice from there I had to
put much of what I'd learned about
combat to the test and learn about the
game stealth mechanics because our next
sequence features a main story Mission
with poppy Sweden joining up with our
player character now in the opening
dialogue of this Mission she asked our
character if we know anything about
horntail Hall which she overheard a
group of poachers discussing now we go
through this little brief investigation
with poppy casting revello and so sort
of finding Clues and eventually we find
our way to a group of poachers standing
guard around a small tent so Poppy says
hey you can use stealth or you can use a
less discreet approach I decided to try
the stealth approach using the
disillusionment charm which we now had
access to at this point in the demo so
by approaching the enemies quietly from
behind you'll see a prompt giving you
the option to press square for
petrificus totalus and unfortunately for
this poacher he'd probably have
preferred I used AK on him instead
a bit further in I wanted to test out
whether or not the enemies would react
to seeing someone hit with petrificus
totalus if it happened in their line of
sight sure enough the poacher on the
bridge over there he hears something is
up quickly comes over to investigate and
yet because I'm still under this
disillusionment charm I quickly slip
away and I don't think they were able to
realize my exact location once the final
game is out it'll be interesting to play
with us a little bit more and see
exactly how that detection Works you're
going to see another example here in a
second when they do detect me this guy
though I don't give him long enough to
investigate at this point I built up
enough ancient magic to actually unleash
one of the game's finishing attacks so
L1 and R1 right there I call down
lightning from above and just absolutely
obliterate this dude right here so after
a few more revelio spells and looting we
make our way into the tint which holds a
rather shocking surprise
dragons
[Applause]
I mean look at that it's like the
Weasley family tent right and Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire only this
time we realize there is a whole dragon
fighting ring inside this tent it's
called horntail Hall we eventually make
our way to the bottom of this area where
poppy and our main character find a
group of poachers with a captive
hubridian black dragon that's right if
you've been following the game for a
while you will recognize this Dragon so
here's where I tried to start the fight
with a stealth approach again but with
the numerous enemies both on the ground
near the dragon and higher up above my
cover was quickly blown I think it was
this guy right here maybe I stepped a
little bit too close and he overheard me
also it's important to remember
disillusionment is not a complete
invisibility spell you know it's not
like the invisibility cloak from the
series and of course even with the cloak
Harry could always be heard but they
didn't give me the option to restart so
I had to just go crazy start fighting
these guys and I had to put all my
combat skills to the test so at this
point we also had access to eight spells
instead of just the slotted Ford you see
here so you can quickly get to those by
holding R2 and then pressing right on
the d-pad again it's all based on where
you have them mapped so not only did I
have access to levioso De pulso accio
and confringo but also Expelliarmus and
even the unforgivable curse crucio the
other two spells were perro and the
disillusionment charm neither were much
help here so the fight ensues
unfortunately for us we have poppy on
our side she's along to help even
deploys a few plants on the battlefield
here and things are pretty smooth
sailing for me for a while until this
moment right here this particular
animagus transforms into a wolf and even
more poachers arrive on the battlefield
alright I don't plan on using dark magic
in the final game so please don't judge
me but finally I had enough of this wolf
and well I had to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
and it was here at this moment I really
started to feel more comfortable with
the combat still nowhere close to
mastering I want to highlight this
particular moment right here because
this is one of my better moments with
combat you could see me Dodge the
unblockable attack again that red
indicator then I nailed this enemy with
Akio follow it up with a quick confringo
shift my focus to the loyalist Ranger
that's attacking here from above Perry
that attack from behind with protego
again the yellow indicator and then go
right back to attacking the ranger even
hitting him with an object by using R1
which is known as an ancient magic throw
honestly that ancient magic throw I
should have been using it a lot more
it's a mechanic that I just did not take
advantage of enough so I'm nowhere close
to Mastery but I can't stress enough
guys just how fun the combat was
throughout my whole playthrough I
thought it was just the right amount of
challenge again I was on the game's
normal difficulty but I found myself
constantly on my toes particularly in
this last battle here I mean things are
just going crazy it's weird you know
going back and watching the footage it
feels a lot slower but In the Heat of
the Moment I have to stress to you guys
it felt absolutely frantic and I mean
that in a good way I was trying to
remember my perry my Dodge all the
combos I could do the ancient magic
attack attack the ancient magic throw
plus all the other spells that I had at
my disposal which I actually kind of
forgot about halfway through the fight
and then right here at the end I love
this you know that little plant I
mentioned that Poppy has on the
battlefield yeah they finish off the
final enemy for us right there so what
do I think about the game are there any
negatives that I took away from my
experience well if it isn't clear by now
I love my time with the game absolutely
loved it the two hours went by in the
blink of an eye when they took the
control away I seriously didn't believe
it I was like wait are you are you guys
serious that's been two hours no way all
I wanted to do was play more in fact if
you think that having a taste of
Hogwarts Legacy has made the wait for
launch easier no it hasn't it's had the
opposite effect I want to play the game
even more I just keep thinking about I
want to play more of this game so all
that being said guys it would not be
fair to you if I didn't point out the
issues that I encountered during my two
hours because I did encounter some that
I have concerns about now we also
reached out and asked kind of what build
was this that we were playing on we've
been told that it is not the final
version and also it doesn't have the day
one patch so hopefully these things can
be ironed out before launch and then
fixed with that day one patch alright so
let's start with the one I think is the
biggest concern at least for me and that
is when I was hit with a loading symbol
before certain doors would open is this
little white circular symbol here and it
happened three different times to me
usually the loading was very quick it
only appeared briefly but one of those
three times you can see that I sort of
back up from the door and then approach
it again before it finally opens I'm
pretty confident in saying that they
want this game to be a seamless kind of
no load experience I don't think they
want you to see any kind of loading
screen so I don't think that was
intentional and even if it does happen
occasionally I mean hopefully it's going
to be like the quick one rather than the
one where you have to kind of back up
and wait all in all though I would still
prefer this over just having a complete
load screen having to take over the
screen I also had another issue when I
was flying around the open world I
decided to stop at this little spot
right here and as I Dismount the broom
you'll see these students kind of just
appear out of nowhere they're not here
when I'm flying in and then once I land
there they are and then just kind of a
strange one it's this lock picking mini
game so whenever you cast alohomora to
break a lock which is a spell we had to
access to in that final mission
basically the way it works is you go up
to the lock you cast alohomora and then
you're taken into this little screen
right here where you are charged with
breaking this lock so I kind of
understand the inclusion of a mini game
like this I mean we've seen it in many
games before even though it kind of goes
against the lore of Aloha more on how it
works it's fine you know but the game
itself it just didn't feel quite right
you have this series of dials as well as
two Sparks that you need to position you
can see the instructions here on the top
right and then they want you to rotate
using the left and right stick now I
even had a Dev standing right by me kind
of guiding me through it and it still
just seemed a little bit unclear to me
and even after you managed to get the
wheel spinning the window seemed very
very narrow so it's like I had to hold
my left stick just in precisely the
right spot and then also start rotating
the right stick as well and really what
you're looking for here is for those
gears on the bottom right to start
spinning but then you just have to make
sure that you hold both of the Sparks
like exactly where you have them so this
one to me I think seems like an easy fix
maybe they change the directions up a
little bit make it a little bit more
clear what you're supposed to do and
then then also maybe increase that
invisible window again we can't really
see the window but just make it so it
doesn't have to be so precise and truth
be told even with my complaints it still
only took me a minute I went back and
looked at my actual footage to see how
long did it take me here to actually get
through this it still only took one
minute which is not too bad it was more
the confusion than anything that
bothered me just wasn't exactly clear
what I was supposed to be doing there so
all in all I absolutely cannot wait to
play more Hogwarts Legacy I was
particularly impressed Honestly by the
visuals there are a few graphical
glitches here and there you might have
noticed again this is not the final
build it does not have that day one
patch but even on performance mode I
thought the graphics looked great
getting to play what felt like a very
stable 60fps personally 100 I am going
with the performance mode no questions
asked as far as how it feels to move
around the world I thought the character
was very responsive it generally felt
good to move it felt good to cast spells
when it comes to the spell casting
system particularly in combat I think
they've absolutely nailed it it feels
fresh different than anything I've
played before certainly my miles better
miles better than the old Harry Potter
games and I also love the unique
challenge it provides while also giving
players options for different play
Styles and really being able to find
your favorite spells figure out the
combos you like and then tailor it to
your own style you know set up those
slottable spells in a way that works
best for you now one thing I wish I'd
had more time to do is just run around
the castle and see what all you could
interact with I tried it a little bit in
the library and I also tried it outside
when I was running along the beach I
tried to cast accio on one of these
leeches right here it was a little bit
surprising that accio didn't work to
kind of pull that leech to me instead I
had to walk over and press the square
prompt to pick it up and then some
things in the library would interact
when I cast a spell like this little
picture frame right here and then others
were not just for the heck of it I had
to cast incendio see if it would burn
any of the books I also couldn't get
over just how immersive and cinematic
this whole experience felt I told some
of the folks there I said This truly
felt like a new story in The Wizarding
World I mean right up there with
watching a new film that that's what I
felt like when I sat down to play it oh
my gosh like we are in The Wizarding
World again ready to experience a brand
new story and frankly this is only
scratching the surface the tip of the
iceberg if you will just of our footage
alone that we were able to get here
while we were at this event I have so
much more to discuss from my hands on
time with game the full mission alone is
packed with a ton of new information so
you'll definitely want to check out my
full playthrough provided without
commentary by clicking the video on the
right side of your screen now so much
more Hogwarts Legacy content coming your
way as always guys thank you all so much
for watching I'll talk to you again soon